what are you tuning hyper parameters or
trying out different ideas the learning
algorithm was just trying out different
options for building a machine learning
system you find that your progress will
be much faster if you have a single real
number evaluation metric that lets you
quickly tell if the new thing you just
try it is working better or worse then
your last idea
so when teams are starting on the
machine learning project I often
recommend that you setup a single real
number evaluation metric for your
problem let's look at an example you've
heard me say before the deployment
learning is a very empirical process we
often have an idea code it out for an
experiment to see how it did and then
use the outcome of the experiment to
refine your ideas and then keep going
around this loop as you keep on
improving your algorithm so let's say
for your CAD classifier you have
previously built some classifier a and
by changing the hyper parameters and the
training set or some other things you've
now trained a new classifier B so one
reason always evaluate the performance
your confidence is to look at this
precision and recall the exact details
of what's written and recall don't
matter too much for this example but
briefly the definition precision is of
the examples that your classifier
recognize as cats
what percentage actually are cats
so if
by a has 95% precision this means that
when classify a said something as a cat
doesn't 95 percent chance it really is a
can't and recall is of all the images
that really are cats what percentage
were correctly recognized by your
classifier so what percentage of actual
cats are correctly recognized
so if classify a has nine 'thus and we
call this means that of all of the
images in say your def set that really
our cats are a accurately pulled out
ninety percent of them so don't worry
too much about the definitions of
precision and recall but it turns out
that there's often a trade-off between
precision and recall and you care about
both you want that when the cost is said
something is a cat there's a high chance
it really is a cat but of all the images
of our cats you also want it to pull a
large fraction of them as cats so it
might be repose to try to evaluate the
cross size in terms of this precision
and this we call the problem with using
precision Recology valuation metric is
that if class i8 does better on recall
which it does here the class IB does
better on precision then you're not sure
which crossfire is better and if you
trying out a lot of different ideas a
lot of different hyper parameters you
want you to quickly try out not just to
cross paths but maybe a dozen
classifiers and quickly pick up the
quote best one so you can keep on
iterating from there and with two
evaluation metrics is difficult to know
how to quickly pick one of the two or
quickly pick one of the ten or so
whatever command is rather than using
two numbers precision and recall to pick
a crossfire you instead define a new
evaluation metric that combines
precision and recall in the machine
learning literature the standard way to
combine precision and recall is
something called an f1 score
and the details of f1 school aren't too
important but informally you can think
of this as the average of precision P
and recall are formally the f1 school is
defined by this one two over one over
precision plus one over recall and in
mathematics this is called the this
function is called the harmonic mean of
precision P and we call our but less
formal you can think of business you
know some way that averages precision
and recall only instead of taking the
arithmetic mean you take the harmonic
mean which is defined by this form there
and it has some advantages in terms of
trading off precision and recall but in
this example you can see right away that
off by a has a better at one school and
assuming f1 school is a reasonable way
to combine precision recall you can then
quickly select cross by a over classify
B so what I found for a lot of machine
learning teams is that having a
well-defined def set which is how you're
measuring precision recall plus a single
number evaluation metric sometimes I'll
call it single real number evaluation
metric allows you to quickly tell if
caused by a or caused by B is better and
therefore having a death set for a
single number evaluation metric this
tends to speed up iterating it speeds up
this iterative process of improving your
machine learning algorithm let's look at
another example let's say you're
building a cat app for cat lovers in
four major geographies you know the US
China India and other the rest of the
world and let's say that you're two
qualifiers achieve different errors on
Indies in data from the supportive in
geographies so alpha may achieve
vehicles an error on pictures submitted
by us users and so on
so it might be reasonable to keep track
of how well your classifiers do in these
different markers or these different
geographies but by tracking for numbers
is very difficult to look at these
numbers and quickly decide eval from a
or algorithm B is superior and if you're
testing a lot of different compilers
then it's just difficult to look at all
these numbers and quickly pick one so
what I recommend in this example is in
addition to tracking your performance in
the four different geographies to also
compute the average and assuming that
average performance is a reasonable
single real number evaluation metric by
completing the average you can quickly
tell that it looks like algorithm C has
a lowest average error and we might then
go ahead with that one if you have to
pick an algorithm to keep on iterating
from so you work those machine learning
is often you have an idea you're
implementing and try it out you want to
know whether your idea helped so what
we've seen in this video is that having
a single number evaluation metric can
really improve your efficiency or the
efficiency of your team in making those
decisions
now we're not yet done with the
discussion on how to effectively set
evaluation metrics in the next video I
want to share with you how to set up
optimizing as well as satisfying metrics
so let's take a look at the next video